sur ces images le ministère de la
défense russe exhibe ses chars en
mouvement une démonstration de force
alors que la guerre continue de faire
rage
les troupes de vladimir poutine ont pris
le contrôle de plusieurs zones clés
comme ici en rouge tchernobyl zappos
rogers ersonne mais leur progression
n'est pas aussi rapide que prévu à
chacune de leur avancée les rues se
heurte à la résistance de leurs
adversaires
la capitale qui a fait toujours debout
sous contrôle ukrainien les habitants
restés sur place se préparent à l'assaut
est imminent
non loin de là aux abords de la capitale
les civils tentent de fuir pin cité en
ruine rasée par les bombardements
plus à l'est à 500 kilomètres de kiev
les missiles russes pilote un
assemblement la deuxième ville d'ukraine
rares kif ici cet hôpital est rempli de
civils blessés comme ce petit garçon
dans un état très grave c'est dommage
nous étions tous à la maison
l'obus a touché l'appartement a explosé
à l'intérieur a mis le feu à deux
parties du bâtiment monfils s'est blessé
un éclat d'obus est entrée par sa
mâchoire et s'est logée dans le coup en
haut de la colonne vertébrale c'était
hier il a 8 ans
au sud-ouest le port d'odessa est une
cible stratégique le long de la côte
l'armée russe s'est déjà emparée de rere
sonne et encerclent toujours marioupol
la prise de desa permettrait de
contrôler entièrement l'accès à la mer
noire en ukraine et d'influer sur les
échanges maritimes face à cette menace
les habitants ont bloqué les routes avec
des sacs de sable pour ralentir
l'arrivée des chars ennemis